non ce n'est pas sans francisco mais la
bastide blanche quelque part entre
ramatuelle et la croix valmer lieu de
prédilection pour les hippies même quand
il ne s'agit que de figurante cinéma
jean girault a en effet installé son
équipe près de saint tropez pour son
quatrième gendarmes
le gendarme se balade
le comique français numéro 1 louis de
funès a repris du service avec un
uniforme pas très réglementaire ou de
finesse on se laisse aller dans la
gendarmerie nationale ah oui non mais
vous vous êtes devenu hippies ou quoi
j'avais l'annoncé des faits une séquence
du genre en dieu de du gendarme se
balade
quel est le sujet de ce nouveau jardin
le sujet c'est que nous
la gendarmerie nationale ad la haute
direction nous met à la retraite
subitement sans explication parce que
physiquement correspond pas du tout aux
normes modernes ils ont pris les
gendarmes de tous deux 2 mettra un hymne
aux honnêtes gens qui ne sont plus aux
normes l'esprit non plus une fois la
porte d une allocation de charbon et 35
milles francs par mois
c'est très amusant si vous devriez plus
engagée alors ou dans l'argent lors dans
la gendarmerie vous chez les hippies
qu'est-ce que vous préféreriez à la
gendarmerie
oui oui la chose normale pour quelle
raison je me suis fait beaucoup d'amis
avec les gendarmes
je suis très aimé que les gendarmes sont
très gentils avec moi